interprets it that way. Destiny interprets it that way. JT and
Quean sending people to his Kiwi farms is why he wants them dead.
I'm talking about So, you need like a little bit more information.
I'm not moving the Gold Coast. You just said just asking for
their age is okay to avoid moral condemnation. I said asking
for their age and having something like a social group for like
additional context would probably be less. Why are you interrupting
me? What are you doing? Because you interrupted me. Okay. So,
I was saying I moved the goalpost. That's not true though. What
do you mean it's not true? Is there a moral fact here that you're
ignoring? No, I'm going by like legal definitions of what you
did. Okay. Well, I'm talking about morality. So, no
major speaking. I want to roll it back. I'm right. You were literally
responding to me saying that I and then you interrupted me saying
I was moving goalpost. I literally said you are interrupt. No,
you were moving the goalpost. That was after Major Windy. Stop
speaking. I wasn't interrupting you. I started speaking first.
Are you all right? The Willamac video giving weak criticisms
of Destiny's sexist allegations causes a fight with dickers myself
and Kelly Gene. Here's the context that caused the disagreement.
It'll be important later. It's Rose's real age saying you were
negligent in verifying her age even after you joked about her
looking so young that you would need her ID to make sure she
was really even 18. The only other time I heard this allegation
of Rose being potentially underage is when I interviewed Kelly
Gene. He he tweeted like a bit over a week ago that the Rose
girl was an only fans girl. She's not. She never she never had
an Only Fans or verified her identity. Why is she known as like
a fansly only fans eirl? She sold nudes via Twitter. So, it's
not it's not that we're trying to say Destiny's a it's that we're
saying Destiny is reckless. I'm going to be real. She does end
up doing that. It's very much what she would imply. She'd list
all this evidence for why Destiny should have been suspicious
that she was underage. Also, didn't bother to check someone's
like age, right?
Join the Okay. Hello. Hello. Hello. Hello. Hello. To be fair,
okay, to be fair, I feel like if we give Willie Mack a little
bit of charity, we could say it's an internal critique. He did
what he's alleging that Jess and uh um Queen have done, right?
Mhm. Who are we shooting? Who are we in a forest somewhere? If
you give like um a charitable interpretation just for RA, I don't
know if you heard it. Um you can say that it's kind of like an
internal critique. And so he's saying, you know, even if what
Destiny's a legend is true, blah blah blah blah blah, it's still
the same that um it's still the same that he did to Anna. He
has a charitable view of what he did to Anna and he has no charity
for what he did to Destiny. Maybe maybe before before I before
I before I leave my hunches before I leave my hunches here, I
would like to hear the exact quote like word for word like if
we can play it back then and you share with us gamma. I don't
know if you're capable of doing that. I just the way I first
heard it the first time and then the way was characterized the
charity I disagree with but I don't want to like go in here if
we you know if we both have incorrect facts or I have incorrect
facts. Can you do that for us camera? Yeah. Tune in you guys
watching the stream. Okay cool. Number or not which is obviously
he's framing it as not malicious but if your docs is on there
and everything well yeah I mean you know they it comes off that
way. It feels that way and and I would interpret it that way
myself.
Yeah, especially since we were literally still at that time.
According to alleged text messages only 2 days before. And it's
not just me who interprets it that way. Destiny interprets it
that way. Jay stalking Queen sending people to his Kiwi farms
is why he wants them dead. I could I house into it. I shared
that. Okay. Okay. Can I do like another like 20 seconds? What
is he talking He's talking about like Destiny telling people
to go to uh Anna's Kiwi farms and you know discuss in the thread
there. So he's directing people to Anna's Kiwi Farm after he
sent them there. I see I see what he's saying and I I guess we'll
we'll get more into it. But I see what he's saying. He's saying
he's basically saying uh he's basically saying that uh you want
to listen. Let's listen. Let's listen together. The doc wasn't
on there until after Destiny directed them. But he gave like
to a thread and like Yeah. sent people to a to a thread me. What
the hell? Cuz he told people to like go there and talk about
me and stuff like that, make make accounts, things like that.
And yeah, I felt like he obviously when I asked him about this
framed it in a not a malicious way. Okay, I got it. I got it.
I got it. Oh, so um with all the facts here, right? Mhm. Willie
Mack has enough information and in that exact Ryan Beard clip,
he goes over the timeline. There's no reason you shouldn't know
that the do like so I guess if I can summarize you're or both
of you the the thing Willie Mack is thinking in his head is Destiny
doesn't want and it it is reasonable for Destiny to be mad at
Queman and Jistle for pointing to the Kiwi Farms thread because
I don't think Anna's doc is there and then he doesn't want Anna's
docs. Okay, so what is he saying? What am I missing? So he's
saying that Destiny is complaining about um Jay Stalk and Queman.
That's his complaint. His complaint is Jay Stalk and Queman pointing
people to his Kibby Farms thread. That's exactly what he did
to Anna. Yeah. Interpretation of uh of what he did, but this
is the exact same reason why he wants Jay Talk and Queen dead.
Yeah. So he's being he's being a hypocrite essentially for uh
for you know for allegedly for these people allegedly you know
sending people over to the you know uh Kiwi farms even though
there's uh maybe he says that later that there's no evidence
of uh Jay Stucker Queen actually doing that. But but I see I
see what he's saying. He's saying that uh that Destiny would
100 be be a percent be a hypocrite for for you know for even
uh complaining about this. Does he make that does he make that
critique or is he just so I feel like it's implied but he doesn't
make the critique vote verbally at least not yet. What I what
I feel is okay that is that is critique he's making right what
I what I feel is disgusting about just like the this all of this
right is that we are platforming one person's accusations against
other people and then not hearing the other side he just assume
like he dislikes and has made it clear he dislikes Jer dislikes
right because whatever right we don't know why but I can infer
why but we've got all of Destiny's best arguments on the record
and I find that and then well he also doesn't like Cali Jyn but
But he's had her on to confer. Yeah. And I don't think I don't
think he's taking a shot to to malign her, right? That's because
it's convenient, right? He he's that's 100% the fact because
Kelly Jean attacked him. He didn't she There's so many bad things
in this video. So in the beginning of the video, so in the first
conversation when Willie Mack goes on Queen's show and Kelly
Gene hot drops, Kelly Jean is upset that Willie Mack platformed
all of the allegations about Kelly Jean and laugh without double-checking
it. So instead of in this video correcting the fact that Destiny
said, "Oh, Kelly Gene is posting nudes in Discord." All that
was false. There's no evidence.
Even though he made that false uh platforming of of accusations
against Kelly Jean, he doesn't he doesn't then correct that in
this video. He starts by saying Kelly Jean says that Destiny
might have been with a a underage woman. It's clear that that's
false. No, he does correct that. He does correct that in this
video to be fair what he said in the last one. That's why he
got um that's why he got Lav and what's her face on the type
of mistake that he made. I agree. He didn't look into it. Well,
he then redoubles down and takes Destiny's word for it again,
does he? About what? About the Well, so it's a different topic,
but the Age of Bros. He does the same thing. He makes the exact
same. Well, he just says that there's Oh, about the Tinder thing.
He He assumes which isn't even true that you have to get an ID
on Tinder. Yeah.
Yeah. He just takes He just took Google's word for you. You don't
need to We went through that earlier. Yeah. And he frames Kelly
Jean as well. He she insinuates he's probably dating dating someone
who's underage when she was clearly like I don't know but here
are the facts like she he frames her as a bad person and gives
Destiny all the charity in the world but I'll hear your argument
the other way. Um and I think he definitely is a little bit kind
of like whatever with with Kelly although Kelly be clear. Come
on.
I would ask that you make a let's not say whatever. They either
say he was good, bad, or neither or neutral, but I feel unfair
is not or whatever is kind of sitting on the fence. What I was
saying, he makes like a because I'm trying to remember what exactly
what he said. Uh he made some kind of comment about um about,
you know, Kelly. It's like a commentary that he gave in the meanwhile
and was like, uh, you know, she uh she did later go on to actually
claim that though or him being a pedophile or whatever. And I
don't know if that was fair because I don't I think I can understand
him having an honest misinterpretation of that. That's a lot
of good reasons to dislike Kelly and look at but what he's doing
is when I let Kelly Jean call in. Is there would there even be
a reason why she would want to call in on a on my stream?
I mean if she wants to she can talk to these guys but I have
literally nothing to add to this. This is like you know out of
my realm. Like spicy made that conversation like worth watching
right? If she wants to converse with these people I'll let her.
I don't mind, but there's really nothing here. He's having Kelly
on. Yeah, at least that I could do. That is what she needed.
She needed to make her argument more clear. Okay. I think Kelly
needed to make her argument more clear. That's a good point,
Wicked. Uh, you know, um, that he's essentially engaging in kind
of like recklessness. If wants to stream later, if you go to
him and he can host the conversation on his stream, but I don't
think he'll be able to provide anything go with somebody. I hate
to break your argument there. I think she used the word reckless
to define his actions. Yeah, but that's not the end. She definitely
seems to imply that Rose is like underage. I think she at least
from what I remember 18 or 19 and the the the evidence we had
that's what Destiny says though. I think the evidence we had
otherwise was that just uh Destiny said in Justistic's DMs that
I don't know her age. Yeah. Those DMs got published and I think
what Kelly's doing in that moment is kind of juggling. I don't
know if I can release the information I have in my head, not
knowing that maybe that information was already out there. So,
she's kind of I can tell I can tell what she's doing right there
is trying to go through, okay, what information is I'm guessing,
right? But let's just say I don't know that information. She's
clearly said, I think she says very clearly like he doesn't know
her age, but from the evidence might be 18, might be 19, but
saying only fans only fans clears him of the allegations, which
is unfair cuz Destiny didn't know. Still doesn't know. All I'm
saying is that uh Kelly probably should have made it a little
bit clearer that she's not saying that Destiny was with an underage
girl. She doesn't know what her age was, but it's kind of like,
you know, it's at the end it's kind of reckless, but there's
nothing more to really say about it. There's definitely reason
to think that he should have uh have double checked or at least
for some kind of verification, but he asked her age. Oh, sorry.
She said she was out of age. Go ahead, window. Sorry, it's not
my stream. Sorry. Go on. We've got 200 milliseconds of ping.
Sorry. I thought the pub argument she made was really weird.
It's the exact discussion we've had before about, you know, assuming
the age of people that are at a 18 plus bar, you know. Um, she
took the exact opposite position that we did where you said you
can assume reasonably that people there are 18 plus where she
said, you know, like you still should have check.
Well, I'm saying I'm not here and and all even Grant, right?
I'm not here to say she probably made the best argument. The
reason she was first and whatever is just the same reason why
President Sunday was half of the last video. It's the same flavor
of from Willie M. It's I don't like this person or I have some
preconceived notion. There's no good reason for this to be at
the front of the video as Kelly Jean other than and because the
fra the way he frames it and sets it up is look how wrong she
is, right? Which I I just think I just think it's disgusting.
I just think it's and look, you may be right about the nature
of her argument. I'll grant that. I don't think he's treated
Kelly Jean poorly. I might have to go go back and rewatch it,
but I think I think he's treated relatively fairly. I didn't
get that sense at all that that he's been unfair. I think the
worst he says that like I couldn't verify this or she she didn't
end up sending this through. You know, I think in his mind, Kelly
seems like she's making the argument that Destiny was with an
underage rose and there's no information to like verify that
that's true. Okay. Which is no information to verify that it's
straight. She What's interesting is I know exactly the sort of
evidence she's citing, but she didn't know exactly where it was.
I know. She should have got someone else to find it for her because
I know that the exact tweets and stuff that she's talking about,
but she didn't have them in the end. Well, what I'm saying to
double check as well. Hold on, hold on, hold on. Let me interject.
The way I see there's two ways to present evidence. He's like
I And maybe again I'm biased so I can understand. He could have
presented that evidence like here's the fact that Kelly Jean
gave out. Here was the good one and here's the one I couldn't
verify. But I felt like and I think we need to relisten but maybe
it's not an important point I heard in my head and what came
through my ears was Kelly Jean said he was dating an underage
woman and that wasn't true. Something to that like it just it
felt like he didn't present the facts as they were. He framed
what was what she up which may have been she wasn't clear but
it was clear he was frontloading what was the bad action she
did or the misinterpretation to clearly put her out as like fresh
as what she
well yeah I mean I will say in to side with right for a moment
at the end of that segment he says congratulations you're not
a right so he t he basically uses he takes jelly Kelly Kelly
Jeans sort of failure to make the argument properly to then sort
of clear destiny of that like claim definitively. Do you get
what I'm saying? So I mean he kind of then takes that failure
a bit too far in the other direction whereas the correct take
is there's no real way to say either or you know either way but
you know you can there's no evidence to say that. So you could
just leave it off the off the table. But yeah, he makes if you're
making a if you're making like a commentary video, there is unfortunately
no evidence to kind of kind of definitively say, "Yes, boom.
Here it is. Destiny was texting a girl who was underage." There's
just you're not going to you can look for it and you're you're
not going to find like the slam dunk thing that kind of proves
asking for, right? Well, I think that's the kind of standard
that we probably should have for these claims. Yeah, cuz you
can't you're not going to She claims that she was of age. There's
reasons to think that and the that Solo seems to like imply that
she wasn't of age, but he's like a religious actor. He's not
reliable. Um, and so there's nothing to to kind of give strong
evidence to the fact that she is uh underage. So, and then the
only allegation there, right? The only other evidence are those
joking tweets that Destiny had with her, but they're ambiguous
and not really definitive. Mhm. And then there's just circumstantial
evidence that she was on Twitter doing this stuff and not on
some verified platform like Fansley or whatever. Yeah, she was
like news on Twitter or whatever. Yeah. So there circumstance.
So you've only got circumstantial evidence and US evidence and
unreliable narrator evidence. I don't think we need the fact
of the matter. I think well it depends on whether I don't know
whether school's DM is in the has been published. I believe it
has on a stream a while ago or maybe you tweeted it because I
know where he says I can sweep anything except underage stuff.
Yeah, it does imply as well that he didn't know. I think it's
explicit. Bring Kelly in. Bring Kelly in. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Give
me Give me one moment.
I was uh I was setting up a roll so that people could just join,
but uh I'll pull.
Go ahead. Oh, okay. Oh, Kelly's here. Fantastic. Yellow. How's
it going? All right. What's the opinion being shared? cuz I only
just got here. So, I was outlining uh Dickers had come in as
well as myself and we were analyzing kind of the pros and cons
of whether Willie Mack framed you in a negative light or whether
he was rather neutral about your interview and whether he used
that interview to then give Destiny validation. Would you say
that's fair, Deckers or Wendy or Gamma? I'm about to pull up
the introduction of the video again real quick so that we can
look over. It's more about framing than it is what I said or
both. I think he takes he he he established he says that you
you sort of failed to prove the claim in the end. It's what he
says and then he takes that to um say for certain that the allegations
are false. Sorry. What is the claim that I failed proving? Cuz
the claim I'm making is nobody knows what her identity is. I
think he frames it as you were making the positive claim that
she was underage. I mean that's how it ends up being used quite
clear.
Yeah. Yeah. In the beginning of the video I made it very clear
at the start that I don't think he's if she's 17 I don't think
he's the age of consent in the UK is 16. Okay. If you 16 17 year
old I don't really think you're a I just think you're a freak
and very reckless and irresponsible whatever. But this is about
like
kind of the equivocation. It's about creating like video content
and them sending and distributing. That's that's a problem. It's
a like separate problem, right? Um but I think that it seemed
like at certain points like you sounded like you were making
the case that she was underage or that she was 17. And I think
that's what he like commentary, bro. Well, the case is being
made that he doesn't know her identity and we don't either. That's
the case I'm making. Not that she is 17. More so that we don't
know if she's 17, 18, or 19 at this point. We don't know. and
to then and to then like speak to someone in that kind of a context
when you're not sure of their identity is irresponsible. Right.
So I think he then treats your claim which I think is actually
very fair and reasonable. It's our tag as well that we just had.
I think he takes that sort of ambiguity and sort of fact that
there wasn't such strong evidence for it. I think he takes some
of that ambiguity and then like frames it as the claim is definitively
disproven. He says at the end of that segment, I don't have like
conflation. I think there's conflation going on between your
moderate claim and the strong claim. And then, you know, he treats
your claim like a strong claim. And then, yeah, I think that's
I don't have strong evidence for her being 17, but he doesn't
have strong evidence for her being 19. Nobody has strong evidence
for her age. So, the default being that she's telling the truth
would be stupid because there's as much evidence for that as
there is I have for her being 17. Right? the point is nobody
knows. Therefore, to engage in that way is reckless and irresponsible.
Yeah, that's all evidence. We're just talking about the only
evidence is like ambiguous sort of tweets. There's sort of Destiny
sort of messages that Jay talk he doesn't know. There's Solo's
messages where he's but he's malicious actor and then there's
just circumstantial stuff, but she was on Twitter instead of
the verified platform. So, there's not really anything particularly
compelling. Yeah. He also tries to bring up Tinder, which is
stupid cuz anyone that's used Tinder knows that like there is
no like default verification for age on that thing. It's just
not true. I don't know why he brought that up as an example.
If she had been on Only Fans, that would have been legitimate
because they do verify. He he literally just say here's the problem
is that uh Willie asked a question that let let Destiny slip
through the cracks a little bit cuz he asked is there is there
any like you know any anything where you like to get an account
you need to like verify your age obviously meaning like you have
to you know show your ID to prove that you're that age but Destiny
goes uh yeah on Tinder you have to say that you are above 18
it's like yeah but there's no verification he's talking he's
talking about verification Not in terms of like, yeah, she claims
to be 18. We all know she claims to be 18
um or claimed to be 18 at the start and then obviously had a
birthday or whatever, but Destiny's able to say yes cuz it's
an honest representation to the word of the question, but obviously
to the spirit it's um yeah, he kind of slips out of that. I think
he asked explicitly for did or something digital identify does
he at some point? I don't remember the term did being bring up
brought up. Mhm. I mean, I just have no interest in trying to
prove he's a because I I just don't believe that's likely to
be true. So, like, why would I try and make that argument? That's
the first thing I say. It's like, I don't think he's a and I
don't think anybody does. Yeah. No, we saw it. No, we all we
all caught that. Yeah. And then he says, "Actually, she sounds
like one here." And I'm like, "Where where in this conversation
does it make me think that I sound like I think he's a I'm like
baffled." But so who brought it up first? Did you bring it up
or did Willie ask you about that? The thing um I didn't record
our conversation. It was quite long. Like we spoke for probably
about an hour and I think he only used like what 10 minutes or
most of the entire conversation. So I honestly don't remember.
The only time I heard of the allegations of Rose being potentially
underage is when I interviewed Kelly G and then it goes into
like a you know Oh my god. Okay. So messed it up. Wasn't me that
uh was circulating on her age at first. That comes from Solo.
That's where that the source of that is Solo completely. Yeah.
Yeah. I mean, everybody was aware of this as an allegation. Uh
the fact that I was the first to bring it up to him just means
maybe I was putting in more effort than other people were. But
I I'm surprised the Solo's messages on the Kiwi Farms thread
to be honest. That seems a little uh I don't know. I think also
the problem is is like it is fair that you don't platform an
allegation that he is a I get where you're coming from on that.
But I do think since Destiny has stated he didn't know the age
that is worth platforming. But Willie didn't do that, did he?
Well, I think here's the thing. When Destiny says he doesn't
know the age, it's like what do you mean you don't know the age?
She told you her age. But I think what he's saying there is like
he's not certain of her age. Yeah. I mean, can we all agree that
I think that that's just not adequate? When you're like exchanging
nude videos online, somebody says they're 18. That's like good
enough. It's not good enough.
Not for a 35 year old content creator who's like been online
to know about these things. It's just no unverified platform
like that probably is not sufficient and then you're sending
them videos that you haven't even okay with other people as well.
if you're giving the uh just on the point of like verifying someone
else's age, I don't know if by default we usually expect people
to like ask for like a picture of someone's ID, right? I don't
like Destiny. I I think that obviously like everything around
it has been reckless and it might be that she's, you know, under
when you first started. You don't necessarily even need to do
that, right? But for him, his like the bar of like being responsible
should be higher, right? You can't just take someone at their
word for it, especially if they're saying they're like 18 specifically.
That is like you should obviously be more skeptical. In the UK,
I think if you look under 25, you're IDed for alcohol, right?
Yeah. So, like, but this guy is like, "Oh, 18. Yeah, that's fine."
No, it's not fine. Be more responsible. Here's Lauren Southern
Son's name. Here's a video of the three people I've been with
last here's the thing. Ideally, it'd be a lot better, right?
But in terms of like if somebody's asking for the age, they are
checking to see how old the person is. And I don't know if we
can like create the expectation or I don't think the bar is by
his own somebody's like a picture of somebody's
by his standard. He doesn't know he by his standard. That wasn't
very No, no. I I don't know if I like the by his standard argument.
We're going on. Okay. Well, I can criticize him by his standards,
right? Does he criticize people for not like asking for like
ID if somebody he wasn't she was of age and she had he had already
sent her videos then meaning he isn't sure if he sent someone
underage videos then yeah I feel fine criticizing for that. The
thing is also the law doesn't care because the ownus and the
responsibility is on you. If you do something like significant
with someone that's underage them lying is not in your defense.
It won't work.
the the responsibility is always discretion. Well, I think if
it goes to court I haven't done criminal for a while discretion.
Well, I haven't done criminal for a while, but I do remember
if it's like there's different offenses for different age brackets
and for the age bracket that's just below age of consent, you
can get that. Uh there is a defense for mistake of age or like
deceit of age. But obviously like for like 12 to 11 that doesn't
work. It's only for the one that's just on the borderline. But
that's like criminal that's like Griffith Code provision that
I'm familiar with. I don't know if that applies in the UK, but
even ignoring the law though and talking about it like morally,
I don't think that we generally have the expectation or I don't
think it's reasonable to have the expectation that you know people
should be asking for like an ID or a photo of somebody's ID um
before like online. You're talking
flirting videos. You just shouldn't do it. I think you shouldn't
do it on these unverified platforms at all. You just shouldn't
do it unless a significant context clue. this person's like like
a doctor or something with something where it's so obvious that
they are already an adult.
Yeah. And also there's multiple issues with this, right? If she
was under 18, that is receiving a child born and if he's sending
videos that he didn't have the consent to share, that is an additional
issue. Okay. So, it's not just like but that's a different issue,
right? Well, I'm just saying you're saying it's not um to with
someone you shouldn't have to see their ID, but that's not what
we were talking about. No one cares about someone just although
like probably you should have more responsibility when you're
as old as he is. I think we do have like higher expectations
for someone when they're in their 30s question if he was 19 or
something not be random he's never met and sending their tapes
and receiving their tapes especially without consent. But that's
the thing we're now trying to bundle it into everything whereas
I'm just focusing on the the verification of the age. That's
all that I'm talking about currently. He should have simply stopped
speaking to this person obviously. Yeah. If you if you get a
hint of uncertainty, we've had this discussion about with the
glass the glass stuff. This practice is so risky. You just shouldn't
do it. Or and if you get a whiff of it, even if you are doing
it, you should just stop immediately. Yeah. Uh he should see
her face. Never even asked the age. Did he see her face? Did
he get like a like she had a profile picture? She had a face
picture in her profile picture, but it was like in a like some
sort of a ho face, whatever the hell it's called. Like it was
you couldn't really discern. I think it was just her mouth. Yeah.
There was some sort of face pick. Yeah. Or even just that. It
was not very discernable. Didn't say much. Yeah. I I get where
you're coming from, diggers. I like I get the idea that, right,
we're not going to like the same thing with the gas station liquor,
right? You walk in, see somebody with a beer gut and a beard,
you're not going to say, "Wow, you didn't ID them." Right? I
get it. Um, and there are certain situations. Okay, so here's
the problem. I'm not is that I I think that it's we can create
this standard now talking about destiny, but realistically somebody
I know that's what I was just trying to get to. I I knew you
would I would hold a consistent standard. Yeah, cuz I'm just
I'm just going on to it and saying sure, should he have done
something more than ask their age? Yeah, sure. I I feel like
I'm open to that. I feel like I probably agree with that. But
then the question is what? And the only feeling I can come up
with is like show an ID which is probably not really the bar
to engage in like online
doing those things with a random person. Destiny has like hundreds
of other options. I don't know why you're making it out like
it would be difficult to just avoid this kind of situation.
I'm not making out difficult to avoid the situation. So why are
you saying oh so what is your point? Like are you trying to speak
to the like the every person and what they should do if they
were in this situation? Like I don't What's your point? I'm just
talking as like a rule in verifying somebody's age. Cool.
Somebody's age. Cool. So, wow. Destiny could have had somebody
else. Cool. But I'm not talking about Destiny. I'm talking about
the general principle or the general rule that we'd hold. That's
60 seconds where I was going to make my point, right, that you
interrupted to remake your same. So, the rule we would hopefully
have escalations, right? Flirting or basic DMs, right? Asking
is totally fine. We wouldn't ask as a rule that you get a DM
with a ID before you start flirting with somebody. You probably
ask for the age and then you engage in the flirting. And then
maybe as things escalate where you're exchanging nudes and things
like that, then especially as someone who has access to multiple
people or a creator who engages in these quote unquote multiple
dynamics, maybe then we would say, okay, if you're going to exchange
photos or videos, we would say as a rule, you should have an
ID or have some additional I would even substitute for the ID
something like a face shot or a picture where you can infer,
okay, god, it doesn't look like they're under 17 are under 18
or you have a verified platform, right? I would substitute the
ID for many things in this scenario, but he doesn't have any
of verified. What kind of verified platform though? Only fans.
Unless they're like an Only Fans creator. All right. That's a
perfect example. You can verify yourself properly on Tinder,
but you have to opt into that. There's like different verification
options, and one of them is I think that just verifies that your
face is real, right? No, there is two different types of verification.
you have to opt into it specifically, get a screenshot of the
right type. Um, but there's also other things you can look for
like on Facebook. They're quite specific with what you can put
on Facebook with your names and stuff. And then you can look
at like people's classmates and like when they went to school
and like figure out from those years and these things like well
I'm just giving you examples of what you can do to like check
that someone is within the age range that they're claiming to
be. You're worried that ID, asking for an ID is a tough ask when
I think it's weird to I I don't think it's fair to hyperfocus
on the ID. That would be perfect, but there are other things
that would give you that ability, their friends, who they know,
where they've lived, like their family, and these these are all
like indicators of like where they are in life. Do they still
live with their parents? Like these are things that you should
just check. And if you're not sure and you can't find enough
information on a person, then probably don't sleep with them.
Like I don't know. Yeah. I mean, sure, in terms of best practice,
I agree with you. I'm thinking about what I'm going to morally
condemn somebody for. I don't think it's going to be condemnatory
if somebody doesn't go onto somebody's like personal Facebook
account and tries to see what year their friends were born. No,
we're just giving you We gave you a list of examples. I know,
but here's the thing. to verify and be certain that somebody
is of a certain age. That's going to be quite a substantial reveal
of uh somebody's personal information, right? And so I can understand
why people wouldn't want to give that out. And so I I don't think
I'd be able to like morally condemn somebody for it because it's
just not going to be what you think. Hang on. Hang on. This is
pretty easy to just say. So there's something like that you're
supposed to do when it comes to these type of situation. It's
called due diligence, right? If you can demonstrate that you've
done due diligence to avoid like committing a crime like these
would be right then people are going to look at you differently
and if you're not making any of these steps like I no that's
not good enough that's simply not due diligence. Yeah. Well,
however, you're hiding. You're smuggling into the word due in
due diligence argument over what the due 12 years old on the
other end using chat GBT. He would have there would be nothing
different about the situation, but you would say you wouldn't
condemn him. The photos you'd be able to tell Royal if it's a
12y old hopefully
isn't going to have the same person using other photos. The person
could be using other photos, but you're saying there was no verification,
right? There was no Yeah. Here's the thing. We're always going
to be able to think and they've stolen they've stolen their sister's
ID and they've proven it proven it even using that way. Right.
There's always going to be a way that you know this can happen
that a child can like you know end up like an adult without either
of them acting maliciously. Right. Right. Right. There are indicators
that you're not in that situation. You get on a like if you know
I wouldn't fall for a scam either. Right. Cuz I would usually
have indicators like a video chat or a call where I'm not talking
to a 12year-old girl. But in your situation, he did have calls
with her. Are we verify he had a call? I don't think we actually
know. I don't think I don't think we actually know if that's
true. I don't know if that's true. They um they said they had
called her. Well, he said that he's had it to he said that to
Pixie. I was close to this person.
Oh, okay. Well, anyway, I think I'd probably say that in terms
of somebody like you're beginning to like uh like to somebody
probably asking the age, that's fine. due diligence in terms
of then like it isn't in any just laying out my position, Kelly.
It's not true though. What do you mean it's not true? Is there
a moral fact here that you're ignoring? No, I'm going by like
legal definitions of what you did. Okay. Well, I'm talking about
morality. So, well, okay. So, you think the absolute low effort
of just asking someone's age is good. Well, the standard is I'm
saying that's probably the that's probably the bare minimum to
avoid being like morally condemnatory. Yeah. Or avoid moral condemnation.
Okay. But if I'm going to finish what I was saying, I think that's
probably to engage or to start engaging with somebody, that's
like like a fine barrier to entry, right? But then if you have
like warning signs thrown up or something, maybe you should ask
for like a certain amount of uh extra information to try and
like verify it, right? So like the whole living with the parents
thing, you would encourage like laziness in this type of situation.
I'm just You can morally lazy someone. I want to I want to encourage
everyone listening right now to be but like you can I'm not encouraging
anything. I'm saying the standards by which I would judge be
doing this anyway. I agree. It is completely fine and completely
understandable for me to think that's only asking for someone's
age when there were additional tone indicators within the things
that she was saying is simply not good enough. Yeah. Like did
I not reference the additional information that would make it
make it more suspicious? This is what make it so you would I
need to ask for more information,
probably just stop, right? Because without all right, without
tone indicators, right? So there are no so say there are no tone
indicators. Say she didn't mention the parent stuff or whatever,
that's it's still not good
Um it's like for a due diligence to be there, you would need
to know more about the person and to not know who they are. And
this doesn't require an ID. If you don't you you could give your
full name and you would be able to look up a lot of things with
even that we don't even have a name like we just have an alias
that is exactly you're thinking perspectively of what somebody
should do to operate in the best and I'm and I'm saying yeah
I agree in terms of best practice and how to like operate morally
I agree I'm talking about in retrospect what I'd give a moral
judgment for so my moral judgment is that that's still reckless
if you they've said their age when you don't know who they are
you don't know their name. You don't know where they're from.
You've never met them. You don't know their friends, family,
circumstances, where they live, you know nothing. They could
relate due diligence, you would have to include at least some
other personal information to think that that age could therefore
be
If right, if we were to get off this call, end the stream and
I was to send a picture of my and he was to send me a picture
of his back, right? I know that he's like 21 or whatever, but
I've never seen his ID. I don't know what his real name is. I
don't know what what state he lives in. I know very very little
personal information about him as most people don't with like
most online uh most online interactions they have. Would I be
what? Improper in doing that? Would Gamma and me recently to
be honest? Right. Both Gamma and I would be acting uh improperly
in doing that because we haven't seen each other's ID. We haven't
looked at each other's Facebooks to look at personal information.
We don't know each other's like full names. Here's the I think
we're thinking about this in the context of do we judge really
the moral condemnation is recklessness right that's both GMA
and I would be reckless if you don't if you if what you just
said is true you don't really know each other and you've only
spoken in like a Discord call a couple times you have no reason
to like believe that his age is actually 21 based on anything
else that you know about him then yeah but I I get the impression
that's probably not accurate you probably there probably are
reasons why you would believe that he is actually 21. We know
he's got monetization set up. We know he's got like, you know,
you can hear him, you know. Yes. Right. Things that you can use
and not be I don't know.
Major Windy hasn't got any any hasn't got any YouTube monetization.
We've spoken a few times. Okay. I know that he's like supposedly
in his like late 20s, right? Yeah. Don't remind me. It bothers
me. It would not be it would not be reckless. I don't think it
would be worthy of like moral condemnation if he and I were to
not having personal information. You're also treating this like
it's a vacuum.
You're treating this like it's a vacuum which is incorrect, right?
Cuz people know you and Gamma and therefore you're aware of like
the community around this, the mutual friends and like the information
that might make this sound absurd. How does that how does that
did you just meet him? No. So there has to be additional context
that you're implying is there that I'm unaware of. There's something
really tricky about the social circle. How does that give me
any information? How does that verify that [__]
Knowing the information of a social circle, knowing that other
people also believe this person to be 21 for information they
might have. These are additional things you would take into
consideration. Believing it does not make it verifies. No, it's
not as there were hundreds of people
reporting Twitter messages where she's like showing off her.
Is that verification? Those people believe it. I'm not talking
about verification. You're saying the bar for moral condemnation.
That's the what I'm now going by your Okay. So, this is not as
high as ID verification,
but this is simply more information. And that makes more reasonable
to like morally condemn someone. If a whole social circle and
a whole other bunch of people believe someone is a certain age,
then it's probably more reasonable to think that that person
is that age. Yes. I don't think relying on the fact that other
people believe it will ever mean escaping moral condemnation.
If there's a risk of if yes, I know I'm saying the words moral
condemnation. If there's a risk of moral condemnation, we'd never
we'd never give we never give into the fact that like, oh, other
people believed it, therefore it was like fine. I think trying
to escape recklessness. You absolutely need to verify that in
of itself. Oh, not on its own.
This is after asking their age. So, it's the only thing this
is going.
I've been trying to get this point out for like 15 minutes. Unfortunately,
this is a tricky one because Destiny's got some context clues
that we don't have, but it's as a result of his really reckless
behavior cuz he's had got photos and conversations with this
person that we don't have. So he's at the beginning at the outset,
yes, he's been reckless because there not really photos of this
person. He doesn't know who they are. They're not on proper platforms.
But then through his reckless conduct, you know, that's reckless.
We all agree. And then he's texted that he's continued to like
indulge in this behavior. And then through that, he's got more
context clues such as photos like that, more correspondence that
we just don't have. So he's sort of cured his recklessness in
that. So it's tricky in that he's he has context that we don't
have, but it's through this recklessness. So it's kind of point
in time is important as well on this. I'm just annoyed cuz moved
the goalpost from what would we consider this to be for like
moral morally condemnation and then which is what I was trying
to engage with and then he put it back on to like actual age
verification which is not what I was talking about. No no I I'm
talking about so you need like a little bit more information.
I'm not moving the gold post. Just you just said just asking
for their age is okay to avoid moral condemnation. I said asking
for their age and having something like a social group for like
additional context would probably be less. Why are you interrupting
me? What are you doing? Because you interrupted me. Okay. So,
I was saying I haven't moved the goalpost. No, you didn't. You
interrupted me. Kelly speaking. I want to roll it back. I'm right.
You were literally responding to me saying that I and then you
interrupted me saying I was moving goalpost. I literally said
you are interrup No, you were moving the goalpost. That was after
Major Windy stop his speaking. I wasn't interrupting you. I was
speaking first. Are you all right? So, you said age like simply
you simply asking for someone's age means that they can't be
morally condemned. I said if you ask for their age and have additional
context clues like a massive social circle that all believe that
someone is the same age and they know they seem from your perspective
to know more about this person, maybe their friends, whatever.
Five minutes ago, Kelly. Yes. The point is you just said only
asking for their age avoids morally moral condemnation. I added
a bit more and you're saying now that this isn't enough. So you're
not making any sense to me in terms of moving it moving the lines
between like verifying and moral morally condemning things. I'm
not talking about verification. You literally said that a minute
ago. I'm clarifying cuz you like you mischaracterized what I'm
saying. You was talking about it literally just a second ago.
Okay. So just
clarify that. Okay. Cuz to like just to clarify, I'm not talking
about moving the goalpost at all. Right. in terms of doing some
basic level that you could like feel like you know somebody's
age. That's age verification, right? Some kind of additional
information to try and like corroborate the age that they've
said. I'm not saying looking at their ID. If I meant looking
at their ID, I'd say looking at their ID in terms of ID
verification of their age. I'll I'll use that word if that's
better. I'll use the phrase verify the information of their age.
Well, it wouldn't be verifying, would it? because you wouldn't
have it. If you get additional information, you verify. That's
literally what verification means. It would not count as verification.
Anyway, looking quibbling over definitions. Okay.
My point is that it wouldn't necessarily be that you escape moral
condemnation simply by asking. It's going to be contextual. And
I already said there's going to be barriers where if you find
additional information, they're talking about living with their
parents, they're talking about going to school, right? You might
at that point might actually be reasonable for you to to expect
you to either ask for more information or if they're not willing
to give it probably just like no that would lead to a condemnation
from you, right? Yeah. I'm saying you'd be obligated. Why you
bring that up? Because Kelly brought it up. Well, then we're
talking about the condemnation still. I am talking about condemnation,
Ro. I'm I'm saying just cuz you ask for the age that you don't
totally like obvious you don't totally free yourself of moral
condemnation, right? Because I've already said there can be other
factors that would incur like additional obligations on you.
Oh, we have those other factors, right? Don't I mean, maybe I'm
confused. I'm not here to I'm not trying to be a but I feel like
we have other factors that point towards questionable things
like you said like the
school what the point of this was like who is he establishing
this rule for? I don't know like the rule it's not for a particular
person. It's like a rule. I think he's pretty consistent. He's
we've I've talked to him about this with Glass and we are quite
he's quite consistent on this. Um, this is not just a Destiny
thing that he's talking about. I don't know. I think I think
this is paying off. Major Wendy Kelly's got a good point in that
age verification is going to be actually impossible and it's
sort of for the reasons mentioned which is that, you know, you
can always fake something and there's always some way it can
be faked, you know. No, it's not impossible. If we're talking
actual ID, there are websites that can ID like verify things.
Um, not I'm not talking about Only Fans. There are like ID verific
there there are when it comes to the due diligence that we associate
with sort of morally morally if you you should be doing more
than simply asking their age you should know more about them
for in any number of ways there should be more than simply that
to believe a person Kelly Kelly to be fair to to be fair to them
right so you would agree properly that you wouldn't ask that
somebody get an ID before they start flirting right um no I think
there are other things that for flirting no at all for flooding.
It's like relevant. I don't Okay. And so what about like just
textual based? What I would say is if you don't if you're unable
to verify someone's age, then you are opening yourself up to
people ridiculing you at the very least that you might have ended
up with a child. So it's like, do you want that? I don't We're
not talking about ridicule. No, I'm saying other people. This
entire conversation has been about moral condemnation. Okay.
And where does ridicule come from? It's the same thing. I think
we can from mockery from humor not from what is the motivation
what is the motivation for that can be a motivation of ridicule
for somebody for having a small it is a result of ridicule destiny
I can ridicule destiny for having like a tight foreskin it doesn't
but you can do both right it talking about someone small
you can overlap you can use ridicule to do a moral condemnation
yeah that's my point yes you're opening yourself up to that.
So like why would you why not just be smarter? I don't know.
Why do you want to always pick the worst options? Again, you're
talking you're talking perspectively
in terms of what choices would you do? You want to avoid ridicule,
don't you? I mean, yeah, I'm talking perspectively. I'd probably
agree with you. All right. But I'm talking in retrospect of a
moral condemnation. What are we going to condemn somebody for
in retrospect? For being reckless and irresponsible for not doing
that due diligence to like a point. Yeah. But Yeah. But of course,
but ridicule can just sound like h like it doesn't have to take
those things into context. If you're caught like someone that's
underage, people would just do that. It doesn't really matter.
They don't have to engage their brain. Yeah. But why are we talking
about ridicule? Because that is a result of your actions if you're
irresponsible. So probably don't do it. Yeah. Like Yeah. Yeah.
Okay. Well, I mean, if you wanted to point to something for condemnation,
we're focused on sort of the process to get there. But at the
end of the day, if you look at at the end, like when J messaged
him, he was uncertain even sort of then. So, like if you want
to point something for condemnation, it's sort of the uncertainty
with which he's gone through this whole relationship with her
and talked to her. Regardless of what the particular steps were,
he himself has not satisfied himself, you know, to a reasonable
degree. He's not even certain. You know, I think that itself
just instead of gloss, you know, gloss over for a moment all
the particular steps he could have taken, he's not satisfied
himself that she's of age. Well, no, that's not even even under
Kelly's standard, certainty wouldn't be necessary. Having like
a a social network where other people believe it to be so that
at no point though you getting like certainty, right? No, that
would No, no, no, no. That example was just for moral condemnation
and not for Destiny's situation. Not with what he did. It wouldn't
be applicable to him. If he was simply speaking to her and maybe
that would have been fine, but he did more than this, so it's
not applicable to him. Wait, what? Are you saying he doesn't
meet the standard of having like have a social network? No, no,
no. But I'm saying by your standard of what you would judge somebody
for. It'd be You'd kind of need some additional information.
You said like having a social network, right? Sure. There would
need to be cuz he knows absolutely nothing about her. Yes. But
I'm just saying in the abstract to Wendy that even even in Kelly's
thing u you wouldn't you'd never get certainty. It's it's a really
really hard hard standard to say that you need to be certain
before you then engage in this stuff. That's why that's why I
added the qualifier to a reasonable extent. That's why I always
add that in there. It's a little sort of escape route little
escape hatch you know like reasonably lawyers and you always
add the word in reasonable. If you think you've got a standard
in uh to a reasonable extent uh you know to what a reasonable
person might do I mean we could give we could give a list of
things we would think were like a decent level of certainty.
So if they were on Asian like websites and stuff, right? Okay.
Yeah. I mean, I mean, but the problem is, I mean, when you're
just two people DMing over Twitter, you're always going to be
limited in how much you can really verify it, you know, cuz I
could I could get my my father's ID and do the the identity check
thing and then send that to you, you know, and doc the PDF or
whatever and you'd never know, you know, screenshot it, print
it out, scan you, you'd never be able to really figure it out.
So, you know, there are mechanisms that for organizations to
check IDs, but you never know who's actually sitting there doing
it if you're just texting the person, you know. So, but you need,
you know, you should be able to take steps, you know, look at
their photos. Oh, that it's got a LinkedIn, they've got a linked
profile, they're already a doctor or like a engineer or something
teacher, you know, oh, they've got monetization, you know, things
like this, that and the other. Like the stream. We don't have
enough likes on this goddamn stream. Isn't that right?
But I agree with Kelly. Kelly Kelly always is always she makes
good points and she's right here too. You need to do a little
bit more than what did you know she's right on British naval
history and she's got a good point on this as well.
British naval history. You always talk talked about it before
in J stream. Yeah. No, I just hoard random facts. I don't know
if you like me. But um yeah, I mean I think the best I think
you it's tricky as I said before because what Destiny did is
really reckless, but unfortunately he might have cured the recklessness
by indulging in it and getting further like contact and and uh
images from this person. So like it's just I it's tricky. I'm
not saying I know there's a whole bunch of defamation going around.
I will I No, none of us are saying that. Okay. We don't want
to get Billy Mitch. All right. But um I would love if he took
me to court for
That would be the best day of my life. Sorry, what? I don't get
to let people say what they want to say so long as they don't
slander somebody. I would call him one if I felt like he was,
but I don't think that Rose looks.
God [__] I don't think Annaine I just don't that
doesn't really scream for me. It's like a pedophile if it wasn't
malicious slander. It's more of a if I genuinely I'd call Kitten
House a terrorist if I thought he was a terrorist. Godamn calling
him fatballs more anyway. Just call him that. He's heard pedal
a million times already. Destiny. Yeah. Weirdly it does. Yeah.
In his role plays. No, he wants to be the kid. Okay. He wants
to be the
royal miss. We all agreed just to send off at a point of agreement
that it's reckless just as a bar as a threshold issue just to
be doing it on these sorts of Twitter platforms with randoms
you hardly know. You as a you as a creator should probably not
be with anyone period just, you know, as a protection to yourself.
Even if you don't want to get moral stuff, stay a virgin for
life. That's a safe There should be a higher bar for him as well.
Yes, there should be reasons why we He knows better. Yes. Yeah.
Especially since he's so short, you know. Jesus Christ. Hey,
I'm glad I'm glad we got the Commonwealth representation here
to argue this. All right. To inject some chronic sense back into
Okay. Jesus Christ. You guys will be there soon. There was another
point in the video I found he he uh he missed something. Um it
was like a third of the way in. the uh it's just a it's not a
good video. I I feel um but obviously that's my knee-jerk feeling.
Sorry. You go. No, you go. You go. Okay. I was going to say there
was there are good parts. I think the stuff he did with Anna
Kimmy was decent. Um so I'm glad he included that. Yeah. I don't
think it was a bad video. Like my complaints are kind of small
really. I do wish had spoken to him because that didn't help.
I think the tone of some of those bits of the video. Did he ask?
I think he did and just kind of blew him
To be fair, he was that before or after he tweeted that he wanted
him okay with him getting docked. I don't remember the timeline.
I just know that it was me that put him in contact with Lav and
Kimmy. So Willie Willie Mo tweeted he was okay with just getting
docks. Yeah, something like that. Yeah, let me uh it was at Queenman
and Jessica saying that it was something to the reply of like
Um something to I I'm going to look it up, but yeah, he basically
was like, "Yeah, but I hate these guys." You mean you mean to
the You mean to the Yeet tweet? I think I saw that. I think so.
Yeah, something like that. You might see You might be able to
see it if he responds to a yeet tweet. Might be able to find
it that way. Is he saying that that they deserved it or is he
like, "Oh, these guys." No, he said he said all of these guys
He said all of these guys are insufferable. He said all of these
guys are like very dislikable. I think it was a little more than
that. I think it was more than that. I I don't think he like
called for it, right? But I think he was like tagged on to it.
Like I didn't care. It h these two are so unlikable. Even when
they're being threatened with their docks, I can't help but notice
how off
big of losers they are. Lol. During the This is like replying
to the Destiny making well. So I think it's wild when Destiny's
making calling like that. I would police people and I hope somebody
kills them and you go, "Wow, they're losers." Yeah. End. I mean,
I think it's I mean, I I don't even think that's a joke. I think
he's just last conversation. I don't I don't know. It's definitely
to say that. I think it's just he's just seething, right? That's
all it is. It's not actually or like think he's like I think
he just he's not saying they deserve it though, right? No, he's
not exactly.
I think he just maybe that's true. Well, maybe I would argue
perhaps him saying even when they're getting blah blah blah blah
blah kind of implies, you know, it's got the implicit they don't
deserve this, right? Maybe. Maybe. Can I win on that? Listen,
I'm trying to speak for this Willy guy. He's got he's been for
the last few months. Willie Mac is we lost the blood. We lost
the blood of the conversation. It turned into the reitigation.
Speaking of the whole reason it's good Kelly's here for this
last bit just very quickly the whole reason I came in to talk
about I didn't come in here to talk about that's usually when
I go into moral stream but in this in this bit where um he's
you know shall we raised this in chat about Willie Mie Willie
Mac here says that um he's he's talking about this hypocrisy
point where he's saying that you know you're you know you you've
put directed people to Anna's kiwi farms and you're saying and
that's what Jayto and Kelly have done And that's what you say
they No, no. I'm just want to make the point there was a discussion.
I think Shelby raised the point validly as to whether he's actually
like positively making the allegation or will it, you know, that
this is what's been going on in JTalk server or whether like
he's just saying from Destiny's perspective, right? He's lying.
They don't allow things in there. I think it's Well, we know
it's that's not doesn't happen. He doesn't he doesn't direct
Kiwi Farms, especially cuz it had the leaked material on it until
recently. um he doesn't direct to it, but I was just going to
make the point. I was just going to say that I I agree with I
don't think that's what he was trying to say, but he's delivered
it poorly, which is why I think you should should have stuck
allegedly in there. And also textually, just think about the
video we've watched so far. I don't think it really makes sense
that he would be saying as an allegation that it's there because
he's barely talked about Jake up until this point. Like he's
not not even really I don't has he even been mentioned at all.
Barely. So, I don't think it makes sense to like then drop very
subtly this major allegation in like a sentence that's smuggled
into a critique against Destiny about someone that's barely been
in the video so far. I just don't think that's what he was feeling.
I think he was mostly making fun of Destiny complaining about
Just Discord if he showed like absolutely nothing. Yeah. Um it
was Destiny I was accusing of lying about that by the way. Like
screenshots aren't allowed, links aren't allowed. Yeah, I know.
I know. It's just like I don't know. Yeah, I got you.
Everybody you've spoken to, he's never given a shred of evidence.
Yeah. Yes. Yeah. I mean, Kelly has been unfairly maligned here
because
it's suit destiny to do it in many such cases. Yes. The lies
are a bit endless. It's like Kelly got banned from Discord for
he made like the implication of child the other day and I'm like
no it's just the child safety stupid that everyone else has got
banned for like dozens other people and like the fact that we've
like deleted general chats and stuff. It's like well if you had
evidence of that stuff happening you would have had it before
we deleted and wiped like people's chats and the general chats
like a couple days ago. It's like it never existed because it
never happened.
But it's like he just makes a lot of claims with no evidence.
And he did walk the Lav one back mostly because obviously I wasn't
in a revenge server with Lav. I barely knew any info about it
even at the time a year ago.
Nonsense. It made me mad when, you know, I I just don't like
it when streamers talk about child so vividly and descriptively
on their streams like Destiny does. really just chase me the
way he always talks about child and [__] you destiny.
No,
he doesn't do that. Evidence proof. I live in Australia. I don't
want to get sued for defamation. Not me. He's not a He's not
a Okay. Everything I say is a joke. Evidence. I don't want to
get sued. All such a [__] I don't want to get killed,
but you know, you know, all joking aside, he's not a Let's sweep
for Destiny a bit. Okay, we sweep for now. Jesus, he's a heathen.
Everything he's also accused me of, he has also done, right?
So, he accused me of doxing his girlfriend. Like, that never
happened. I've never linked to her docks. I don't really know
what her dox is. Uh, like why would I care? I don't. Bizarre.
Something to do with you like discussing her only fans or something,
which I mean was like public. Yes, her only fans are my free
cam. So like if you look now, although you can still find some
stuff on like other search engines and stuff, she started to
like wipe a lot of things, but like everyone's documented and
archived like certain things. So you can show like on her main
Twitter account, she's talking about being a cam girl and camming
and the same account she uses now, there were like she had a
link tree with her current same name like with like the links
to my free cams and her only fans. The idea that me mentioning
those things is doxing her in some way is insane. I think even
if she had made some effort to hide her cam girl from her like
regular life persona,
um even if that had been the case, if you're camming with your
face and like yeah, easily identifiable tattoos, I don't really
think you have the right for other people to not talk about that.
Like it's kind of you can't even talk about it. It's not personal
information, right? No, it's not. It simply is. It wouldn't be
classified as the dogs. Yeah. But also, she didn't really make
any effort to like hide the fact that she's a cam girl beyond
the fact that like she's now started to delete stuff, but that
wasn't like the case prior to when I spoke about it. And she
also just made a tweet saying being a cam girl with a hemorrhoid
is hard actually or something. Whatever. That's Hey, that's just
how fatty do. That's just how fatty do. Yeah. At this point,
I don't think you then have the right to keep talking about that.
It's like it's a thing. I I don't know. But like it's also like
Destiny also accused me of revenge porning her. I've never even
posted a normal photo of her. So I'm just like what are you on?
Like me posting her. Me posting her, which never happened, is
also not revenge. That's just advertising at most. Especially
since already public. It's It's funny that he quibbles over the
definition of revenge cuz he didn't technically leak it to the
public technically,
but then he uh he'll just like slap you with revenge for sharing
publicly available. He posted my only fans content and I never
one point like accused him of revenge. I was just like, well,
thanks for the free advertising, I guess. Weird
champiciously. People can post it maliciously, but that's not
revenge. No proof. Prove it is in the pudding because when the
Keles thing went down and old stuff of hers resurfaced and was
shared by Kiwi Farms, he didn't call that revenge. Now, obviously
they posted it maliciously to poke fun of her and to humiliate
her, but it's not revenge. It's not You're overing it. It's not
It's not revenge. It's not revenge. It's maliciously posted,
but it's not revenge in the way that you know that that's a recent
term. It's not just malicious. Yeah. Anyway, not just It's just
annoying. It's just annoying because I didn't post any pictures
of her. So, I was like, "What the fuck?"
I don't know. He actually He actually just invents about you
more than anyone else that I've seen. He just makes it up. That's
cuz there's nothing else for him to do because every insult I
aim at him or his girlfriend is true. And he knows that, which
is why he won't go over the things I've said about his girlfriend
because it'll then highlight all the things that about her that
are true. And he doesn't want to do that cuz then more people
know about it. Oh,
Hemorrhoids is nothing. I don't think he wants everybody to like
have her ex-boyfriend brought up when her ex-boyfriend has like
a Wikipedia page and like details his previous
physical abuse and like scamming people. He's like her ex was
terrible and she dated him after he did all of this stuff. was
on heroine was uh arrested for doing fent in the same room as
a baby and was like he's being like charged as well and she's
like oh she's being so mean about my ex who's just like going
through drug um whatever like he I no that's not what I was doing
this guy was a bad person and you ch ch ch ch ch ch ch ch ch ch ch ch
ch ch ch ch chose to date him. Yeah, I mean this is a pattern,
right? What I was doing seems like she's got a type. Yeah, I
was establishing if it had just been Destiny, it would be like,
okay, you're staying with him. That's very weird and for these
other reasons that I don't like. But the fact that she's done
this before, I'm like, that's the these type of women are scum
to me. These are women that truly don't care about other women
cuz like you go for like people like for men that have treated
women like the worst possible ways at like many instances and
you just don't give a like you haven't like publicly said oh
this stuff is bad. The most we got out of her from the baiting
and like the channel was her saying that she'd had some arguments
with Destiny about it and it's just like well that's meaningless.
I don't care. Like this is clearly your type in men and like
what do you even like about him? He's short, fat, ugly. He doesn't
have a good personality. So all there is is like clout and money,
but he's cheap, so good luck. So like, yeah, like if someone
is this and then you're dating them as a patent, either you're
like self-esteem is that cripplingly low or you just don't give
a about other people. You just care about clout and money. Scum.
That is why I think she's scum. Scum. Scum. Scum.
Scum. Are
really
that um he's the one thing stopping Trump from taking over America
though. Campaign, he can campaign better than anybody else. Also,
I hate to sweep. Okay, she seems like a she seems like a nasty
girl, but uh have you considered that hemorrhoids aren't irrelevant
if you're a cam girl, you know? Oh, that's something we might
need to think about.
Workers comp issue. Is that what it is? Not anymore, but I just
feel like it probably hurts the bottom line. Do you know what
I mean? It's like a fly in the ointment. There's probably somebody
inside. Let's be honest. Somebody do every weird thing. You don't
know that every man. That's right. Something like that. Anyway.
All right. Jesus. I feel like you I need a bath or a shower.
You're telling me, dude. I feel like showering again. Camera.
You got to nuke the world. Okay. Surprised your mic is still
plugged in. Camo, dude. I went mute for like the past hour. You
guys You guys completely derailed from what the conversation
was supposed to be about. Oh, we're sorry. What would you We
just gave you an hour of content.
content that I don't care about. This is a you guys conversation.
Gamma Gamma, what would you like to talk about? Oh, well, we
were we were supposed to discuss like the introduction of the
of the Willie Mac video where where he like kind of like threw
shade at um where he kind of threw shade at Kelly. That's what
we were supposed to be discussing and it went somewhere completely
different. You were even listening. We did. Yeah. I went I went
to go get a water bottle. Yeah, I know you guys did. I went to
go get a water bottle while you did it. I don't even care anymore.
Oh my god, it's Kelly. You're such a What do you want to ask
me then about that? I got I I got I got nothing. This is like
this is like none of my my concerns. Oh, he's shaking in his
I literally don't I have nothing to do with this. I have nothing
to do with this. I got struck into this. I don't I
I literally said that I wasn't even going to touch the content
nuke because I'm not invested in anything like DG related. I'm
a complete stranger, dude.
Literally call me Call me an illegal alien at this point. Jesus
Christ.
[__] hell. You don't Why bring it up then? I'm so
baffled by He's Mexican. He's Mexican. Okay. Yeah, it's it's
a South joke. Anyway, nice to meet you, Kelly. I think it's the
first time we've spoken to each other, but yeah, nice to meet
you. Hopefully speak to you again soon. Maybe on a school thing
or whatever. Shout out to you later, Gama. Love you. Yeah, I
hang around in chat, but nice to speak to you, Kelly, for the
first time. Wow, everyone's so nice exchange. Have a good one.
Yeah. Bye. Are you ending stream now? Uh, no. I'm going to continue
watching this video cuz that's what I was going to do for like
the next hour. Wait, where did you even get into it? When did
I get even What do you mean get into it? Uh, in regards to what?
Halfway through. So, so there's you already discussed. I'm not
going to reitigate it, but yeah. Uh, basically, they thought
it would be interesting to talk about the situation, how you
felt about it, but you know, it's already it's already played
through. But anyways, I appreciate having you on though. If you
mean on like a personal level, like do I feel slighted or like
he was taking shots? I don't think so. Like I I spoke to him
earlier and I like I think the video overall is good. There's
like obviously quibbles I have with it. I I don't know. I wish
that he had pushed back on the Tinder thing because that isn't
like valid age verification.
I also think if he thinks that I was suggesting he was a after
directly saying he's not a he probably should have said why he
thinks that cuz he didn't really he didn't um because I I quite
clearly said I don't think he's I think he's reckless and these
are the reasons why. Mhm. Um but I guess I could ask him why
he thinks I think he thinks Peter I don't I might as well I might
as well go to the beginning then uh of this of this video where
where the shade occurred in the first place. Give me one moment.
I got to put out this game that I was playing so that I can focus.
Sure. Give me one moment. All right. So, I just got to go to
my tabs. What a professional look that I have. All right. Let
me share my my screen. Oh, wait. I'm already sharing it. So,
let me put this on uh 1.5. Since my last Destiny video, a lot
of videos with them without the participants consent. So, he
wasn't just sharing videos with Rose, he was sending it to other
women who then told Pixie. I had a conversation with Anna who
claims Destiny sent her don't care. Aaron tells I was like nothing
making it doesn't change anything. I confirm about Doc. Where
was this specifically? I think it's the first section after it's
around here. Yeah, she never she never had Rose. He also threatens
to release Rose's real age, saying, "You were negligent in verifying
her age even after you joked about her looking so young that
you would need her ID to make sure she was really even 18." The
only other time I heard this allegation of Rose being potentially
underage is when I interviewed Kelly Gene. So, he he tweeted
like a bit over a week ago that the Rose girl was an Only Fans
girl. She's not. She never she never had an Only Fans. She was
never on any platform that could have verified her identity.
Why is she known as like a fansly only fans eager girl? She sold
nudes via Twitter. So, it's not it's not that we're trying to
say Destiny's a it's that we're saying Destiny is reckless. I'm
going to be real. She does end up doing that. It's very much
what she would imply. Yeah. Right there. Right there. That's
exactly what I was referring to. That's exactly what we were
supposed to be discussing is how he just basically shaded you.
He like he like threw shade and said that's exactly what she
was implying. That that's what the conversation was about. I
think he genuinely believes that because he just includes it
because if he had put that in the video and then all of the video
after this like and he didn't believe that's how that looks he
would look he would know he looks right but he believes that
what I say after this point looks like or sounds like me calling
him but I'm not sure. I mean, this this part um kind of like
like it it caught a lot of us off guard when uh when I was watching
through it because uh I mean like this is just complete shady
say he like he's literally saying that that you did imply that
throughout the conversation. List all this evidence for why Destiny
should have been suspicious that she was underage. Also didn't
bother to check someone's like age, right? It's like a she never
should she claim she was underage? She said she was 19 to him.
That is true. But she and also the way he goes about facteing
this is completely idiotic. he just like goes to Google but then
upon looking into it a little bit further and looking at the
toos they don't they don't like a they don't like ID verify uh
most of the times depending on the region and and if you do like
you mentioned earlier it would have to be something that you
opt into if you want to also said for Tinder or 18 or 19 I think
she said in messages she was 18 and then turned 19 is most likely
the case she was also saying oh I can't she was saying to Destiny
I can't come see you cuz my parents won't let me so there was
like a lot of like um within these messages sort of tone indicators
that this is a very young person but when someone says is only
fans. There's Okay. I'm assuming I'm assuming that's exact that's
why he said this earlier thing where uh where you imply that
he is in fact a right. Uh because you're mentioning the thing
about tone indicators. Yeah. Yeah. Which you know which is kind
of stupid. It's kind of stupid if he would assume that's the
case based on this alone because that you're obviously not implying
that this gay guy is like you know below the age of 18. It's
just a possibility that the person could in fact not be like
you know too uh straightforward about their age. spreading a
piece of misinformation in his benefit because if she did do
Only Fans, he could say, "Well, this website, which is known
for So, yeah, like there's like two main main parts of this video,
which is exactly how uh you got brought into this, is uh there's
a couple of parts where he just like frames things in a way that
could definitely bite him in the ass. This being one of them,
this being one of the things that he, you know, says it just
I already know people are going to rip into him for verifying
people's identity and age. Uh says she's 19. Therefore, it's
reasonable to think that she's 19 in this." I personally feel
like that is too convoluted. Sorry. Go ahead. Or or did I hear
you here? I can't I can't tell. No, I didn't say anything. Okay,
then I must have heard you on on Willy Mac's video argument.
And if she lied about her age, I'm probably not gonna hold him
accountable. Unless I see evidence that is very obvious that
she's lying or he asked for ID or some [__] and she's
going no. So he does. In this conversation, it just feels like
he's actually not following now now that we got everything in
perspective. like like I'm not going to assume that this person
is younger than 18 even though you you like you know explicitly
say that that you don't think that uh that Destiny's that he's
like talking to a 17-year-old. It appears that he's just not
following that. You know, you already made that clear. Let's
do that. There's also an issue with this and it might just be
genuine miscommunication. When I say so he does, I'm talking
to like one specific thing that he's just said cuz he gave a
few different examples of what he could that could have happened.
And when I say well he does, I'm referring to like the allegations
of like Solo was making about the ID and there were some other
messages in this kind of vein. Like it was something like uh
I can't remember. It was something to do with ID, but it's difficult
cuz I I don't have all the solos. Well, one of the main questions
I'm not sure. Sorry, go ahead. I'll leave you. Yeah, but also
like for my allegation that I thought I was making, which is
simply that Destiny doesn't know her ID and we don't know who
she is or how old she actually is. Um, I thought that this was
adequate, but it seemed like I had to prove that she was 17 to
prove that he doesn't know, which is odd to put that sort of
um It's like putting the onus on me to prove her age when none
of us know her age. It's kind of Yeah. Yeah. I don't think Yeah.
I don't think anybody's alleging that he's like, you know, uh,
more specifically, I don't think anyone is making the specific
allegation that Destiny's talking to somebody who's underage,
right? Just more so that he's being reckless with with the fact
that he's not verifying who he's talking to. So, yeah, I can
definitely see how can this be a miscommunication and he just
assumes age is just one part of it, right? Like, we don't know
her name. We don't know where she's from. We don't know anything
about this person. Yeah. For all we know, this person could actually
be like an agent working against Destiny as well. True. It could
be like a 70-year-old man for all the fans. Okay. So, um, one
of the questions that I wanted to ask, I'm pretty sure they asked
you, but I just wasn't here for it cuz uh cuz I like took a step
out. Do you do you feel do you feel like the reason he he uh
may have like, you know, framed this the way he did is is could
could be because he had a negative interaction with you in the
past or or is it do you genuinely believe that he just like,
you know, um, mis uh misinterpreted what you were laying down?
I think it was slightly misinterpretation.
Slightly. I think he's genuine. I think he believes what he's
saying because why else would you put it in the video? You'd
just like, wouldn't you, if you didn't believe what he's saying?
But I don't really understand why he thinks that I'm alleging
he's a Maybe it's because his definition of is literally a little
bit more under 17 immediately. I don't think most people think
that but also I'm British. Like again, if you 16 or 17year-old
in England, it's legal. Um it's gross but like I don't think
you're if you do it. Yeah. So so maybe maybe his definition is
more well more so yeah it's more broad like he he would consider
any any older individual with like somebody who is uh below the
age of uh I want to say colloquial consent which would be 18
right as most people wouldn't typically want to interpret. He
probably below that would be
the issue here is not that they're having right it's that they're
she's creating what would then be CP technically and distributing
it to him and then he's sending tapes without the consent of
the other people as well. So the like the that would be the problem
that he's got himself into by doing that. Not that Yeah. Yeah.
One of my main criticisms here in this part of the video is that
he's like trying to like you know he's trying to do like the
the you know allegation sort of thing. But the thing is like
I don't think anywhere in this segment anybody actually alleged
that he was a people are just you know a something that was uh
misconstrued in the wider in the wider audience right people
that were receiving this information because I don't think any
is um yeah I'm really not sure where he got this impression from
ask I don't think anybody here that he was like covering uh or
anything that he was covering here like imply that that Destiny
was just saying that it was reckless of him to talk to a person
that maybe could have potentially been a minor but there's no
evidence to suggest one or the other. Yeah, it's reckless and
irresponsible and it's it should be criticized because he's like
a public notable figure, right? It's like behaving this poorly
at his age as well. It's just like shameful. That's pathetic
really. Yeah. Uh but that that's pretty much it in regards to
all of that. I don't think that I have anything more to add that
you know uh would interest you. No worries. I'm going to head
off anyway. No, you're good. I appreciate you uh giving your
input. Bye. Take it easy. I